hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge von
carrie antwortet es ist sommer in berlin
schon fast nur von sieben grad heute um
bei uns ist heute ein ganz besonderer
gast
vor einem jahr habe ich eine klage
gestellt über das gesunde boot kaufen
sein
erinnert ihr euch ja in der glaubt war
das nochmal 62 32 bei 30 31 ja da war
ich am strand und habe diese frage
beantwortet diese geschichte für mich
wer bisher
du schreibst eine frage auf unseren
kanal ich beantworte die frage und
zuguckt gar nicht ob sie beantwortet
wird
und dann hat wirklich eine andere
japanerin hat das gesehen und hat wohl
gemerkt dass die antwort nicht gesehen
hat was davon hat deine emailadresse
haus gefunden und wir geschrieben wie
heißt sie denn sie wohnt in tokio und
bist du dir für die in der nicht nur
leistungs und liebe studiert malerei
ölgemälde glaube ich hatte diese größe
nach tokio fliegen wir treffen wir uns
jetzt heute freue mich in kontakt
geblieben und haben uns voll getroffen
die haben halt und plant sogar
mittlerweile einen besuch in japan
brüderle wird wir planen jetzt ein
workshop zusammen mit dir also in japan
die yokohama nicht perfekt wir freuen
uns wahnsinnig und so was könnt ihr
natürlich auch machen wenn er von
deutsch unterrichtet deutsch lernt ladet
und gerne 1 in eure schule oder uni hier
unten findet ihr immer ein formular wo
ihr und schreiben könnt ja jetzt mal
wieder einige fragen von euch hier
vorbereitet zum beantworten
die erste frage kommt von ich kann mir
nachfolgen dass es ein chinesischer name
ist kannst du das lesen
ich kann auch nicht auf die japaner
genau
erkennen aber ich hab was das bedeutet
auf deutsch missverständnis ein
chinesischer name oder japaner der kann
das frühstück leben
also wie walz personen schreibt ist
helmut ein gewöhnlicher name oder hat
das wort auf eine besondere bedeutung
helmut ist ein gewöhnlicher name ein
altmodischer name also bei helmut denke
ich immer an helmut kohl ja ich gebe mir
eigentlich auch arbeite ich helmut
schmidt bei nemos mitarbeiter oder immer
noch eine alte ältere general helmut
schmidt habe ich nicht mehr aktiv erlebt
dafür bin ich zu jung also helmut ist
ein älterer männer name und der witz an
dem helmut witz war das hell ist er auch
ein adjektiv für hellwach und weißes
mammut ist hell
also ja ich kann schon verstehen dass es
ungefähr das deutsche humor level
dazu passt die nächste frage von henkel
ich kann nicht deutsche wird zu
verstehen bin ich allein nein
[Gelächter]
wir verstehen die deutschen rützel auch
unter nicht und es gibt wirklich es gibt
wirklich eine eine ja eine spaltung und
es gibt auch viele humor nazis körper
seien in deutschland an dass viele leute
kennst du das nein gibt es auch
grammatik nazis sind alle leute die sehr
strengen winters wenn ich zum beispiel
du erzählten witze und ich sage der es
nicht witzig und ich finde sowieso fast
nicht witzig dann bin ich ein humor nazi
monat also es gibt sehr viele leute die
finden sehr viele sachen ich witzig
carne vale seine sache ja es gibt keine
wahl in westdeutschland in ganzen
städten müssen wir das gesehen hat in
unserem video in köln feiern die leute
alle feiern auf der straße keiner geht
zur arbeit allesamt betrunken verkleidet
und in berlin zur gleichen zeit ist
nicht einfach gar nicht mehrmals
getroffen am montag ja ja ja in berlin
gar nicht nein gar nicht mal eine
verkleidung ja
wer dann hier in berlin besoffen
verkleidet rumläuft wer wird einfach
komisch eindruck dann gucken wir mal ob
wir noch eine frage haben heute ist wenn
in diesen hässlichen kostüm
du meinst das kkg trotzdem sagt lady 7
426 1 700 000 27 schöner name schöne
folge wären nur alle deutschen so ernst
und gehe ohne humor vicari und das event
ihn ja nicht dazu sagen das war
wahrscheinlich im sitzen ganze wirklich
ich glaube das war wirklich ein witz
aber man kann ja nicht also humor heißt
ja sehr unterschiedlich
ja das ist eine gute wahl wird das thema
offen
dafür rückt multikulti werde austausch
oder versteck nicht mehr du morgen die
sowohl humor kann menschen
zusammenbringen wie also aus
verschiedenen ländern humor kann aber
auch menschen aus dem gleichen land
auseinanderbrechen
ja ich hab hier glaub ich einen
russischen namen kann zudem auch
vorlesen die hbh bakari warum bist du so
langweilig ich bin ganz anderer meinung
meine mutter hat mich gar nicht
beleidigt aber das witzige war dass ich
hab mir gerade ja geguckt werden gerade
kommentare gesucht die wir beantworten
können und von allen kommentaren zu
unserem letzten video war darf der
spannendste kommentar das muss man sich
mal vorstellen also eigentlich bin ja
ich nicht langweilig sondern ich brauche
interessante fragen damit höher als
interessantes erzählen können weshalb
ein appell an euch schickt uns doch
bitte mal mehr fragen alle fragen zur
deutschen sprache und kultur sind
willkommen und umso spannender euro
fahrgeld umso besser ist auch unsere
antwort ist ja logisch wenn nur solche
fragen kommen kann ja nicht viel
erzählen würde sagen
udo geiger gaida um so gailer werden sie
kommen um so gailer ihre fragen
geiler unsere antworten so einfach ist
danke das war's für heute
diese woche endlich mal wieder ein kari
antwortet seit vier wochen waren wir
nicht unterwegs aber wir brauchen eure
fragen unbedingt dazu wir freuen uns
sehr dass du uns trifft ganz gleichheit
das ist eine große ehre und freude hier
rasten sein und bei euch zu sagen das
war paula ich bin sehr dankbar dass wir
so gut gegenüber mir das auf jeden fall
ein wären sehr gefreut wenn ihr auch
besuchen möchte schreibt uns einfach wir
haben nicht immer zeit wir sind nicht
immer da aber wir versuchen es alle von
euch zu treffen und alle fragen zu
beantworten
danke dass du da warst wir hoffen dass
wir uns nächste mal wie auch in japan
sehen wie weiß ja und zeigt ihr auch
lehrer in japan seit oder lust hat um zu
treffen schreibt uns mal also wir planen
tatsächlich eine reise nach japan im
winter ja danke sie zu sehen und bis
bald
[Musik]